hey there say
do you like fantasy novels the new
worlds to discover
magic interesting species and
all sorts of bizarre things going on
but are there some fantasy tropes
you're done with are you tired of the
stakes being raised to the point that by
the end of the story the entire world's
in the balance
have you had enough of one-dimensional
villains with no agenda other
than being evil are you exhausted by
racially and sexually homogenized casts
of characters
do you cringe when you read the words
ancient prophecy
well then i might just have something
you might be interested in
my name is nathania wayne and i have
written an illustrated fantasy novel
called dreams of fire and
i need a little help getting it
published and one of my goals in writing
this book was to
avoid all of the cliches that i for one
absolutely tired of
there is no prophecy there's no chosen
one there is no
rising evil there is no dark lord
it's a story about people
in a world that i'll drop the humbleness
i'm pretty proud of so that's what it
doesn't have
what does it have well
it's a world that is going to contain
both magic and
electropunk style technology you're
going to have a mix
of fun technology that you don't always
see clashed against
magical elements the story focuses on a
young man
named ferris and ferris is what is known
as an elemental
these are human beings who exhibit
certain
magical traits that they have little to
no control over
he finds himself torn between the worlds
of humans and the magical and very
dangerous world of the fae who dwell in
the forests and the mountains
he is feared by humans but he has
nowhere else to be
and to go he is on the run people are
trying to hunt him down
this is what i like to consider a small
story
focused on a core group of characters
but set
in a large world a world with
conflict with grapplings for power but
from the perspective
of the people on the ground there will
be large events
that occur over the course of this story
but this is not a story about the movers
and shakers
it's about the people just trying to
live in the world
if you're interested in some more key
details as to how i've approached
certain elements of this book
and you want to get that kind of
information before considering funding
me on this kickstarter i have
provided a playlist of author diaries
that i have put out
so far and there will be more on the way
as i continue to work my way through the
editing process which brings us to
what exactly are you funding well
at this point the book is almost done
it has been written revised repeatedly
it has gone through beta reading already
it is in the editing process
what the main thing that you will be
funding is to ensure a professional
level of presentation
so that means things like a
professionally designed book cover
a professionally designed world map and
the big thing illustrations i mentioned
that it was an illustrated novel and
i can't actually tell you why i had that
idea
but once i latched onto it i couldn't
let it go in my ideal world
i will be able to to pull together
enough to have an illustration for every
chapter
in the book but even if that doesn't
happen the main purpose of this
kickstarter
is to allow me to be able to pay fair
amount
to the artists that i am working with so
that we can have
an appropriate number of illustrations
of key moments and you can get a proper
visualization of the characters as they
are intended to be seen
while the main character of the story is
a young man in his teens
i would like to think that the story
will have appeal to a
fairly wide age range basically anyone
who enjoys fantasy stories and like i
said
is tired of the epic quest is tired of
the evil empire as tired of the ancient
prophecies
and you just want to explore a new
fantastical world and get to know what
it's like to be there
dreams of fire will hopefully be that
now there are
a lot of rewards that i am offering at
various tiers
everything from just the basics of my
absolute gratitude for helping out in
any way you can digital copies of the
book
physical copies of the book signed
copies of the book signed copies of the
book
and prince also signed of the world map
on the higher end being able to name a
secondary character
i don't mean like a background extra
like a character who will actually do
something
and if we go above and beyond the amount
that i currently have this set up for
that will enable me to maybe possibly
hit the goal of being able to get an
illustration for every chapter in the
book
but the amount that i am asking for is
to cover
what i consider to be the key moment
illustrations and have
all those bases covered now you're
already seeing some of the illustrations
i have already commissioned to get a
sense
of what it is you are financing
specifically in regards to this book
because as i said
i'm going through the editing process
already the book will be done
and it will be available the question is
what will come with it what will be
added
to the presentation of my words you can
help make it
something a little bit more unique and i
like to think
a little bit more special but
only you can decide whether or not that
happens so whatever amount you are
prepared to give
and to help is greatly appreciated even
if you're not able to do that
to spread the word about this campaign
if you have friends who you think
might be interested in what it is that
i'm trying to do with this book
and as i said if you need a deeper dive
by all means check out the playlist of
my author diaries and
thank you for listening even if you
don't support me
i appreciate that alone so take care
be well and thanks